Kim Kardashian goes to the shear side  again 34 year old left little to the  imagination in this see-through black  crop top while vacationing in Mexico  last week I can care less what anyone  thinks or says and check out the mom of  two here rocking a rolled-up white tea  with itty-bitty black bikini bottoms I  want to wear things that make me feel  good about myself and still feel sexy  during her getaway game told her  snapchat followers this since we've been  in Mexico for three days and the  paparazzi just got us we're going to  start living our life and snapping and  she wasn't joking she shared tons of  sultry snaps including this bootylicious  video I'm happy and I feel confident  game is back home now but she'll be in  NYC this weekend Kanye at the VMAs she's  set to present at the show I love that